Crafts aesthetic part three today we are going to make a phone holder and
the materials we will need are cardboard,
scissors and silicone.
Now let's get started.
Well,
we'll start with the larger piece,
which is a rectangle which will be your preferred measure.
We're going to roll it up and glue it.
And now with three circles out of the 6 we made,
we are going to mark this in two and cut it out as you can see here.
And now what we are going to do is glue it to the three of them,
the two of them with holes together.
And the last one is going to be the plan.
Then we lined it and it should look like this.
Now we are going to place the roll and the other three that are left over,
which are the best,
we are going to glue it together and cover it the same as the one below,
as you can see on the screen.
Now with a kind of little stick we are going
to glue it to the top of the stick.
And now we're going to glue this one as a roll and we're going to
glue the top we lined and it should look something like this.
Now with two little pieces we are going to glue them in this
way so that they are going to hold the phone and look.
Now you can record.
Here I show you how it turned out.
I loved it. It goes.